sweets sketchbooks and smiles on the way
in
but a serious toning call
we just knew they'd come in and make
sure that everybody's okay body cam
footage was shown of police officers
responding to a call in may 2016
apparently their last row before they
broke up one was asked about red marks
on the actress's face
knowing what our investigation revealed
no it's that pink's consistent with
brian
johnny depp and amber heard's former
agent gave evidence
christian carino says after playing
captain jack sparrow five times in the
pirates of the caribbean films he
believes the actor lost the role in the
upcoming sixth movie because of amber
heard's allegations of abuse i don't
recall whether either of us ever said
anything specific about
why
but
it is something within the industry
that is understood
another witness seemed so fed up he gave
his testimony while driving
i'm tired
i don't want to deal with this court
case
everybody got problems
and i don't want to deal with there's no
one
that was a first i'm sorry
but with several weeks to go there'll be
plenty more people dragged grudgingly
into this messy legal battle claire
gregory sky news